welcome to this video playing what is
made yeah what is made I think you
should know what I made us if you play
chess it's pretty helpful alright let's
see okay we play play the English
Defence the b6 line which I played
rather often against c4 here in online
chess some quite interesting way to play
delaying the f porn so that you can
sometimes set up this kind of Dutch
structure this guy is playing slower
than me this doesn't happen too often
I'm waiting for him to maybe play a
three-year giving me a tempo but doesn't
it doesn't happen somehow oh yeah this
is a normal move I just I just forgot
that you can play it even before I take
on c3 hmm that's a problem really
yeah cannot play a fight because f5
hangs and here i need to be need to be
creative here probably in big trouble
here yeah this is why you don't play d
sixer in steps that you take and play 94
I mean not in this concrete position
probably which is not theoretically and
explored but in general okay maybe if i
manage 27 and takes on his success is
still a valid position but yeah this was
really bad play okay I'm the long
diagonal Queen d4 I really don't want to
see this this is not so bad
it could be playable yeah yeah I
probably didn't see 92 but it's not so
clear yeah I got will take the material
anyway the thing is that this Bishop is
quite a force of this leap
it goes back in queens III something
like that of course you cannot trade
Quincy em but I'll wait till five t5
probably yeah I need to get rid of the
Queen's badly
yeah queen bee seven or queen c700 gives
them it can take with the pawn but the
seaport isn't really a dangerous force
in this position
and yeah I think I'm I'm in good shape
now first make sure nothing bad is
happening on the default and I win tempe
a truck takes rook takes as a maid
thread right resign yeah that this is
really lost now I get the sea point for
no compensation at all a very lucky game
I play daddy 636 was a pretty terrible
was far too far to sub superficial I
just need to take him and play 94 this
is the normal way to go about this
position this position type d 6 is
always answered by D Phi completely
ignore this and now I'm in trouble
really trouble the problem is if i take
he has more than one good way to play
can take f5 that's night g5 ideas i mean
for example let's just you know with
this coming it's really terrible the
light squares are terribly weakened and
maybe this is i plate 94 is also a
possibility but this is probably good
enough you have I know I not a move you
like to play but yeah maybe this is
better I I don't know
I was a bit worried that something like
this might happen this or this until
this is why I took the night but of
course this gives why this enormous
bishop yeah one this position I'm still
worse but probably not lost you should
probably not give the exchange but even
that is not entirely clear if he plays a
quick windy 3c3 this is something like
this that's same this is really tricky I
mean how do i how do I cover that I can
play Queenie five if he goes back
something like this it's difficult to
play for win alright thanks for watching